les 24 heures de l'ina ce week-end ou
comment la mémoire de l'audiovisuel
prolonge la vie de ces archives c'est
bien sûr à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine
près de 400 villes participeront à ces
24 heures de la télé michel vial sybille
bromberg
beaucoup d'entre vous crois qu'il ne
reste aucune trace des émissions or
c'est une erreur parce que il est
procédé techniquement un enregistrement
simultané qui permet à la télévision de
conserver ses souvenirs et même ses plus
beaux souvenirs
depuis 45 ans les souvenirs de la
télévision n'ont pas cessé d'augmenter
de volume jusqu'à atteindre aujourd'hui
1 million 250 mille heures de programmes
mais ces beaux souvenirs ont mal vieilli
conserver sur des supports fragilité par
le teint et des dégradations chimiques
qui menace à court terme moins de 10 ans
une grande part de la mémoire
audiovisuelle française pour sauver ce
patrimoine l'institut national de
l'audiovisuel a entrepris un ambitieux
plan de sauvegarde de numérisation
destinés à transférer ces documents
analogique sur fichiers numériques
sur ces 800 mis leurs menaces et nous en
avons donc sauvegarder à ce jour 250
miller est grosso modo nous avons les
moyens passés présents et futurs
pour garantir que 80% de cette mémoire
ça sauvés alors notre combat aujourd'hui
la discussion que nous avons avec les
pouvoirs publics c'est d'arriver à
trouver les 20% qui nous manque de 7,7
par encore qui n'est pas financé car les
techniques pour sauvegarder les films et
les bandes vidéos sont très coûteuses et
si certains document déjà gravement
endommagées ont pu être numérisés et
préserver leur état nécessite une
opération supplémentaire de restauration
nous ne pouvons pas faire de la
restauration systématique alors que nous
faisons de la sauvegarde systématique
donc la restauration pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur c'est c'est un pour
cent de ce qui est sauvegardé qui sera
restauré la numérisation permet
d'accéder très rapidement l'arche yves
et de découvrir des choses qu'on aurait
du mal à à découvrir sur l'ensemble des
cassettes et si on manipulait que des
cassettes et des bandes et des films ça
serait très très très insidieux
grâce à la numérisation li na est
devenue la première banque mondiale
d'archivés audiovisuelles en ligne 225
miller et 2 millions de notices
accessible aux professionnels sur
internet depuis cette salle ultra
sécurisée comme un coffre fort
c'est la mémoire désormais numérique de
la télévision dont les émissions servent
aussi à raconter l'histoire de france